underworld blood Wars is the fifth
underworld movie that's right the fifth
one now we've had some okay fifth
installments and franchises before but
when it comes to this series I was just
like wow they're actually picking
another one okay let's all go see it
it's January it's the first weekend in
January's the first time of thiers
movies in January it's January holy fuck
so in this one Selene played by Kate
Beckinsale is trying to keep her
daughter safe despite the fact that she
has no idea where her daughter is
because her daughter has a very rare
blood type and this particular blood
type is very sought-after by vampires
and lichens because it's like SuperDuper
blood because it's hybrid blood that of
a lichens and vampires and so everybody
wants to get this blood nobody knows
where this girl is literally no one I
actually really enjoyed the first
underworld film it's not a great movie
but it's a fun vampire movie with some
impressive action sequences and good
cinematography and Kate Beckinsale in
leather is never really a negative so
there's always that but after that they
got increasingly worse and underworld
blood Wars is just a big paycheck I
think I think a lot of people are hoping
to get some money out of this and I
don't know the 3d was impressive so
there's that with almost every single
underworld film after the first one I
keep thinking the same thing you have
one job just make it look cool that's it
that's that's it that's all you have to
do no one expects anything else out of
the underworld movies just make it look
cool and this film can't even do that
yeah everyone's costume design is
awesome and the production design is
very cool and there's a lot of SNM and
black leather and all kinds of things
like that that you expect to see and
people are jumping and flipping and
slicing and dicing and shooting but my
god it's edited to shit they have no
idea how to cut these movies together
and it pisses me off the underworld
movies could be really fun disposable
trash but after the first one they've
gotten increasingly worse and they can't
even figure out how to cut action
together and in convincing an exciting
way there's so many angle changes and
they're constantly trying to hide poor
stunt work and the majority of this
movie is just a lot of vampires looking
at each other and doing this
and then lichens will just be like ah
that's underworld blood wars look if I'm
being honest with you the month of
December is filled with tear jerking
movies Oskar films and all these really
heavy dramas sometimes the month of
January and the garbage pit trashed it
awaits me is actually kind of exciting
because you're like oh wow I can just
watch a whole bunch of movies that I
don't have to really think about and in
some ways I look forward to January in
that very small my new way and you can
kind of watch blood wars with that
mentality where you're like this is just
disposable trash it's nice to look at
but it's edited horribly the characters
are just bland as shit and there's all
this narration and exposition in case
you missed the last installments in the
beginning and people are constantly
sucking other vampire's blood so that
they can then have flashbacks to tell us
what happened to those characters in
case we missed that too but I couldn't
quite get blood Wars to that
entertaining trash level because the
action sequences are so boring and the
characters are so boring that I couldn't
even really appreciate it on that level
I'm gonna give underworld blood Wars
a d-plus if you're still a hardcore fan
of the underworld films then just goes
through the movie you're probably going
to like it because if you've liked all
of them up until now then you'll
probably like this one too if you just
liked the first one and we're
disappointed with the others like me
this one is probably gonna be the same
it's probably gonna make like 50 to 60
million dollars domestic and it'll make
its budget back or whatever and I don't
know I might be wrong on that one but
we'll see guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
videos very soon I'm excited to bring
you more reviews in the year of 2017
let's have a good one guys thank you
very much once again if you like this
you can click right here and get stuff
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you